frente a la costa de port gentil esta
plataforma abandonada es símbolo de la
gloriosa era de la capital petrolera de
gabón una época que parece lejana para
mohamed diab y un taxista que viaja
varias veces al día por esta carretera
que hace unos meses era muy transitado
pero hoy en día hay pocos clientes la
crisis económica causada por el cob y 19
ha afectado mucho a la ciudad petrolera
mohamed apenas gana 10 euros por día
este inmigrante marfileño vino a gabón
para beneficiarse del milagro del oro
negro una edad de oro que es cosa del
pasado
hoy en día hay muchas personas que ya no
trabajan al principio hubo el boom del
petróleo el conductor de taxi incluso en
los malos días gana más por lo menos 30
mil 20 mil francos cdf a los fines de
semana podría ganar hasta 50 mil francos
dfa incluso podías negarse a hacer
carreras porque ya había ganado dinero
suficiente
el petróleo es la riqueza de esta
provincia que tiene los principales
yacimientos de gabón el país depende de
casi el 40 por ciento de sus ingresos
petroleros pero en la ciudad desde la
caída de los precios y el estado de
emergencia sanitaria vigente desde abril
la economía está paralizada los
restaurantes son muy poco frecuentados y
los hoteles están casi desiertos
como ven ya no hay mucha gente david le
abrió su hotel recientemente después de
cinco meses de cierre su clientela de
turistas y empleados del petróleo ha
desaparecido los ingresos han caído un
70 por ciento en seis meses
él saben estimaciones que ahorita me
niego a calcular mis pérdidas lo que es
seguro es que después de seis meses de
inactividad todos los gastos y los
salarios que hay que pagar estamos
hablando de millones
o sea todo se ha perdido millones en los
últimos meses al igual que otras
ciudades petroleras de áfrica central
donde la caída de los ingresos por
hidrocarburos se estima en varios
cientos millones de euros
de las residencias también hay mucha
gente que ha viajado la empresa de
subcontratación del león es una de las
pocas que todavía está en el negocio
pero su cartera de pedidos ha estado
vacía desde que se detuvo la perforación
ya que 125 personas dieron positivo por
kobe en varios sitios hoy en día sólo un
pequeño grupo de empleados de la
compañía siguen presentes en la oficina
central
el jefe tuvo que despedir a la mitad de
su personal 150 empleados que ahora
están en desempleo técnico que estamos
tratando de pensar en cómo salvar la
herramienta de trabajo cómo unirnos para
salir de esta pandemia que nos está
afectando a todos logremos el gobierno
por su parte está tratando de hacer lo
que puede para alentar a las empresas
que aún están operando a que perseveren
me gustaría creer que el impulso que se
ha creado a ese nivel se mantendrá
y eso es lo que nos mantiene
esperanzados
bernabé por su parte ya no tiene
esperanza este ex empleado de otros
subcontratistas fue despedido después de
ocho años en las plataformas no tiene
perspectivas de volver a trabajar en un
sector petrolero que ahora está
devastado eso arruinaría su proyecto
inmobiliario en esta parcela de tierra
que acaba de comprar con todos sus
ahorros
mi primer sueño como todo ser humano era
comprar una parcela y construir otra
acaba de ser destrozado sólo dos días
después de haber empezado con las obras
me llama la dirección para decirme
verbalmente que el contrato se terminó
se acabó meses se harán mantilla que lo
contraen de un tris y termina de cayey y
al igual que bernabé cientos de
empleados despedidos acuden a la uned el
poderoso sindicato de empleados del
petróleo cuando llegamos a la casa del
gobernador les dará la palabra así que
tienen que hablar pero no solamente de
su angustia silbe mayab y líder del
sindicato dice que los trabajadores no
deberían ser quienes paguen por la
crisis si ve busca defender los derechos
sociales de sus camaradas en apuros en
su mesa nunca había habido tantas quejas
de empleados despedidos casi un millar
en los últimos seis meses
entendemos que hay una caída en la
actividad lo único que criticamos es que
el gobierno gabonés haya utilizado el
estado de emergencia sanitaria para
emitir órdenes que violan las libertades
los derechos de los trabajadores ese es
el problema y los empleadores se
lanzaron a reinar imponer sus reglas
hacer trabajar dos veces más a la gente
y a quien no quiera hacerlo corre el
riesgo de perder su trabajo
para apoyar a sus empresas el gobierno
gabonés desbloqueo facilidades bancarias
por cerca de 350 millones de euros
esperando así amortiguar el impacto de
la crisis sanitaria y petrolera en una
economía aún poco diversificada